please welcome our wildflower and my
hero jocelyn camarillo
have you ever gotten your nose broken no
i don't think so no
do you worry about something like that
uh no of course not how are you not
afraid uh well growing up boxing has
always been on our tv um
me my family would get together and we
watched the boxing fights and i
specifically remember watching the manny
pacquiao fight versus mayweather yes and
we were all just going crazy watching
this fight was really entertaining and i
think that's what inspired me to want to
try boxing
i mean i've seen things that inspired me
too it didn't mean i went into a life of
it
how do you find the bravery to get in
there and not
be afraid
vain about your face
bold and be petite
and
take on a man
i know this
it's
everything i think sometimes in our
instincts
how are your instincts the way they are
why are my instincts run
and your instincts are
go in
i don't know i guess um well going in i
was very intimidated you know i was
going into this boxing gym where i was
surrounded by most big muscular guys and
i'm this i was this 13 year old petite
you know little five one girl going to
the gym so it was very intimidating at
first but um
you know i just stayed dedicated and
stayed focused and kept training and
you know i proved that i do belong in
the boxing gym i mean you cruised it all
right you won
and
when someone came to you and said okay
you're gonna fight men and women or was
that your decision how does something
like that come about because that isn't
the way i feel like as a sports
you know not aficionado that is not the
way i see it being done how did you
change that well there's not a lot of
girls at my gym and there's pure guys so
i mean it's tough finding sparring
especially for girls so sometimes you
have to just far guys and i don't mind i
mean they make me they made me who i am
today they made me tough and you know
when i do spar uh girls
it's a lot easier because you know guys
are typically more stronger than girls i
mean
what would you say to people
who want to also watch things in this
world and be inspired and get into the
action but
are afraid
um one thing i would say to them is just
you know if you have a goal
no matter how big it is just keep
working hard and stay dedicated
um
what about like dating do you ever like
like this is what i do what are the
reactions um well they're typically
shocked you know because they're like oh
you do boxing i'm like yeah
um so they're like oh i guess so you're
gonna have to be protecting me and i'm
like yeah
but yeah i kind of like that though that
you know i can show them that i am tough
and i can protect myself
okay will you show me some moves yes of
course you know just because i'm so in
my boxing outfit
okay are you
are you right-handed or i'm a righty
okay so you're gonna put your dominant
foot back is that my right foot yeah
your right foot back left foot forward
keeping our hands up to protect our face
let's go left hand one
right hand two
left hook three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
um okay well i'm glad that thank you
kyle
[Applause]
um well um we had a special uh
wildflower robe made just for you from
us a little something to wrap yourself
up in
after a long day
um oh thank you
thank you
thank you my love thank you so much
here
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
what's your favorite thing to do when
you're not boxing
sleep
sleep and watch you know
watch all the movies
what movies 50 first dates really i love
that movie i love that movie
[Music]
um well jocelyn you're just so cool and
i'm so glad you embody what we want to
talk about with wildflowers it is the
pippy long stockings it is the true
fierce spirits out there
who are just doing things that make us
all marvel and believe in ourselves and
be excited to cheer someone on who is
being so brave and cool and rad
yeah thank you so much for this
opportunity thank you thank you
so much you are such an inspiration
to so many young women
and um we can't wait to keep cheering
you on oh thank you
[Music]
you